skip Wescott is the best spider-man
villain hey I think we ready yes you
heard some let's go look first sign is
confirmed NYC is not an autism I've
never been to New York except in the
world of fantasy I am getting real tired
of your [ __ ] whoever's driving this I
think spider-man never ends up actually
finally learned learning how to drive I
know for a while he needed like quick
money so he start like he started trying
to take a test to learn how to drive a
taxi
and he kept going there well yeah we
could just cut over that building and
then the instructor was like you mean go
over it how the hell would you do that
and here's like oh nevermind relatable
anyway um yeah the high part 3 so I did
this weekend wasn't really good to
record one of these I had to wait until
Monday assuming this goes up on Monday
and then I really try for it but uh team
I got to do her missions um oh wow race
models alright but I was going to try
and get this up on Sunday and then ended
up spending most of that day working on
uh the Arkham Knight review which is
getting closer and closer
in fact it's I don't know I I don't know
how I would quantify its level of done
right now if it's like half done or 75%
but I got through editing all of the
hard parts basically and the rest of it
will be rather easy
Wow I overshot that by a lot I was
expecting that to be why it is this one
of the hard races Oh
I could swear I went through that oh my
god I'm not going to get a medal for
this aren't I so that's something that
you could just say a lot in everyday
situations I'm not gonna get a medal for
this please do it anyway
oh my god swear I saw the inside of it
this is this is embarrassing this is
just I I don't know if I can live with
myself after that one
yes we'll retry it so uh I've got
another round of questions from the
comments from part one here let's hope I
can do a little better this time we're
already off to a great start
you know it would be helpful if I wasn't
talking while I was doing this but that
doesn't make for a very interesting
video now does it
um what's my favorite ultimate
spider-man story arc um honestly there's
a lot of good ones but I think all of my
favorites are actually any of the ones
which the kingpin if there's any
character that Brian Michael Bendis can
write really well I think it's Wilson
Fisk and I always love whenever he has a
story with him and I just love the
dialogue between spider-man and kingpins
because if there's a lot of themes of
just them like serve just kind of
talking at each other like they often
it's never really a fistfight they've
more of them just kind of arguing their
different points of view about which
whether one of them is an [ __ ] or not
and while Wilson Fisk most certainly is
an [ __ ] he sure thinks he isn't and I
I think it's the way he's written is
really interesting and I like those
stories I think he's actually the most
interesting ultimate spider-man villain
because ultimate Green Goblin this is
another question the ultimate version of
Norman Osborn is a little obnoxious
because his motivation keeps changing
for no reason it seems like one minute
he absolutely loves her
Osbourne and wants him to be a successor
and then the next he wants to kill him
and then the next he's disappointed with
him and then the next he wants to have
Peter be his son and then the next he
just wants to ruin Peters life forever
and you could argue the same problem
kind of applies to the original version
of Green Goblin but it's not quite as
bad all right here's a fun one fun fun
what for some reason I have an accent
even though I don't have an accent I
just have bitterly mispronounced playing
I remember it
alena some kind of that's our boy Eddie
Brooke I don't get it where's the suit
the suit where we doing town boys you
know if I had to think of one of my
least favorite spider-man villains I
think it's actually in both universes
silver sable and I know what it is about
her she just like is not interesting at
all for some reason like sometimes I
don't know maybe it depends on the
writer but like others when she was
interviewed she just kind of man I was
more interested in what that time she
recruited Sandman and they became like
buddies and Sandman with a good guy for
a while remember that time Sandman was a
member of the Avengers like no one ever
talks about that he was like the coolest
guy in the eighties he was like so nice
and the only reason he was a member of
the sinister six is because hi he's
exploring people is because uh Doc Ock
was like threatening to hurt a bunch of
people that he was living with because I
guess when you're an extremely villain
finding an apartment is Rosco Sandman
was just living with this family who
were like hey we'll take in hey was yeah
I remember now it was that story where
Doc Ock tried to convince everyone that
he was gonna put him down a chemical on
the atmosphere that would kill everyone
but then it was actually that he put a
chemical on the atmosphere that just
cured everyone of the ability to be
addicted to like cocaine so everyone in
the world who has who has an addiction
to cocaine is now allergic to it like
ingesting cocaine puts people into
violent convulsion and then he just was
like yeah and I have the Cure right here
so if any of you out there having
horrible withdrawals you can just like
take it up with me
oh the cool story and then he put a hole
in the ozone layer and then had to undo
it make it forever alone like cocaine
again I think that was I can't remember
if that was before or after he tried to
cure AIDS doc ock did a lot of really
cool geared [ __ ] movie
you know I think it's kind of funny is a
gameplay choice
that enemies don't give you a lot of
health and you have to eat like 50 of
them to fill up but chickens from that
commercial and the only way to actually
get your health back is to consume any
random nearby civilians hey wait a
minute I recognize this this is that
store yeah I liked it
I'd like to detail that all the
collateral damage that Lionel left
behind pays for the rest of the game and
then gets repaired over time how many
people did okay let me ask if like this
massive military operation is going on
we're like 60 people are shooting guns
at Eddie Brock at one time and the
middle scene where the hell is
spider-man like I can go to his house
right now right over there Oh [ __ ] I
got hit by that song do I eat carne I
shouldn't get hurt by getting hit by
them
I think it's more disturbing like that
Venom ISM and killing anyone right now
like in in universe he's just feeding
everyone and that's it that's all
they're feeling it's just him
continually suffocating and murdering
like 30 to go I forgot Venom's normal
jump henna suck there's like no reason
you would ever use this jump because you
have this one I'll learn some other
questions will I play spider-man ps4
when it comes out
no because well not unless I played it
and reviewed it first because doing a
let's play as your first time playing
something I know from personal
experience those old ones I used to do
before I started doing comic book stuff
when your plot when you're doing a let's
play of something for the first time
instead of just playing it like you
normally would it kind of affects your
perception and you're not able to pay
attention to it the way you normally
would
I picked this game for the first let's
play that I'm going to actually finish
play that heavy rain yeah but I picked
this game because I know enough about it
that I can play it not miss everything
like I know what happened and I know how
to play it
you know I always feel bad whenever
people kind of [ __ ] talk less players
for not being really great at video
games because while you're talking
you're not exactly focused enough to be
like really good at something so I can
understand why I like Pat from two best
friends play like that I know that guy
is notorious for getting like yelled at
for being bad at stuff but I don't feel
any like I don't feel like it's his
fault it's really hard to do this sort
of thing I have a lot of respect for
people who can look like do Let's Plays
every day because boy do I have to be in
like the perfect mood oh and for people
who are asking about the frame rate of
the videos here I'll show you what the
game looks like for a few seconds
without my edit post-processing
this is what the footage looks like for
ps2 games I have no idea what causes it
I have no idea how to stop it from
happening other than to just go in and
change the frame rate manually when I'm
editing the video hopefully whatever I
did this times will make it a little bit
smoother like each episode it gets a
little better just because it seems well
I use a capture card and I guess it
records in a certain amount of frames
and unless the game I'm playing runs in
those frames that just gets confused and
then just starts adding a bunch of extra
ones for no reason
lovely back to our boy Pete hopefully I
don't have a whole bunch of dizzy
no okay ooh four consecutive attacks
let's go sit on this person's roof and
test that out actually I think this is
MJ's house ooh cool that'll be useful
what a bland backyard there's like hey I
think this is the spot where Glen died
like right about here in this universe
I think ultimate vert universes version
of carnage is boring as [ __ ] because he
has no personality and he's yet another
fucked-up clone I don't know like there
seems to be a lot of characters in the
Ultimate Universe that had a lot more
personality for them in the original and
then been this kind of writes them to
just be like just drooling monster that
Peter has to hit a bunch of times like I
think I think the original universe
version of venom is far more interesting
because he has he has conflict and a
personality and he has stuff going on
internally and you know he's got to deal
with things like I have this monster
inside of me and it wants to do bad
things and I want to not do bad things
well as like the ultimate universe
version of Eddie is kind of introduced
as a shitty person just for the sake of
being a shitty person like like he's all
macking on Glenn and acting really
creepy despite the fact that she's
underage where is that combat tour wait
I know it is and then you know he gets
the suit and then he's just kind of like
I'm fine with this I like it like the
ultimate universe version of Eddie Brock
I think comparatively has like no qualms
about murdering people and he actually
kind of enjoys it meet
get you around the corner
nice ID I think I'm getting better at
playing and talking for sure though oh I
said right as I got hit all right fine
you you asked for it
all right do it do this do the thing no
not that thing this thing yeah there we
go that is only there to embarrass him
that does nothing to hurt bad guys it's
just it's just a cool thing Thank You
mr. health pickup I don't know why I
wait to pick those up every time because
I don't really need them but like they
feel like an incentive like just so the
noise it makes makes my brain go I did
good
other questions I'm not looking at the
screen right now I'm looking over there
uh it's hard to multitask like this I'm
just hitting the same two buttons I love
that move I should do that one more
often
if I made a spider-man movie what would
it be about and why that's a good
question um well you know I think the
origin is not as overdone holy [ __ ] dude
maybe settle down with that well can you
could you stop please oh oh
I think the origin isn't nearly as
overdone as people say it is like I
don't mind seeing spider-man's origin
because I like it as a story Oh God uh
wow that's that's embarrassing um I
honestly I think I would like to see uh
here's the thing though is I actually am
getting kind of tired of seeing
spider-man do high school things because
I did a video a couple years back where
I was saying that I wanted to see a
young actor for spider-man but now I
think about I watched the young actor
for his origin but when you think of all
the cult like the classic spider-man
stories and all the cool stuff that
happened usually it's after he gets out
of high school when the good stuff
starts by high school is just a lot of
setup and like everything interesting
seems to happen around the time he's in
college or beyond so I would set
something more around the time
spider-man's like 25 at least which I
guess the Sam Raimi movies did but I
don't know they they just there there
was there are some issues of spider-man
3 I want to see maximum carnage as a
movie because you don't have to set up
every individual character you just kind
of have to have them there just because
they're cool like you could play it off
sort of like how guardians of the galaxy
is done where
but but with the villains where it's
just like you give a short run to run
down and who they are and maybe a theme
to introduce them on their own and then
just have them join up with carnage for
his crazy murder maps or saying that
he's willing for because I like the the
moral individual the moral dilemma
spider-man find themself in and that
story is that like everyone he shacks up
with to go fight carnage and if his bad
guys are all like a bunch of kind of
violent 90's anti-heroes like cloak and
dagger and venom and others things
blackhat was there and they're all
they're all kind of going hey we should
kill carnage and his family of idiots
just because like why not and peter has
to constantly argue for like why on
earth would you let a person like
carnage live I mean that also happened
to me during that time that spider-man's
caught like his parents came back as
Android and I would probably omit that
part but you know you know what also
Cravens last hunt would be a cool movie
I don't know actually it might be a cool
episode of a TV show
I actually think after reading the
original series that Spiderman would
probably make a way better long-running
TV series than a movie because it has so
many characters in so many long-running
events and so many things that just like
come back and have consequences if you
gave it the budget of like Game of
Thrones I think it could absolutely work
and it could be the new Walking Dead
because Walking Dead is based on a comic
but that's like America's favorite TV
show you know so I think Spiderman was
fit better there and you know I buy
people don't want to talk about it but I
think one day when the Marvel Cinematic
Universe finally winds down and kind of
any the next logical step was maybe to
do some kind of television universe or
something
can't find a word mission Let's Plays
are cheap and easy
[Music]